the movie begins in dystopian japan the
government has implemented a rule known
as the national prosperity law according
to it one in every 1 000 citizens must
die each year the citizens to be killed
are chosen through a lottery system and
notified one day prior to their ultimate
death the law is supposed to create an
appreciation for life by instilling fear
of death that way the citizens will work
harder to make something out of the
little time they have since they can die
any day for the part about how death is
inflicted every kid at the age of 10
must be injected with a chemical that
embeds a special chip into their body if
they are selected in the lottery later
in life the chip bursts at a given time
and kills them it is efficient quick and
painless at the beginning of the film we
see a man named yusuke frantically
running down a busy road he frequently
checks the time as if he is running late
for something it turns out that yusuke
was notified about his death 23 hours
ago and is about to die at exactly 11 pm
he must do something very important
before his death which is why he is in a
hurry yusuke ends up in a pub and
attacks a man in high school the man and
his friends bullied use k until he had
to be taken to the hospital they burned
his hand with cigarettes and humiliated
him daily in the last hour of his life
yusuke wants revenge on the guy however
seconds before he attacks the clock hits
11 and he dies without fulfilling his
last wish in the following scene we are
introduced to notifiers the people whose
job it is to inform the chosen citizens
about their fate 24 hours prior to their
deaths they are specially trained for
years before being employed since the
news of death is not something the
government takes lightly the instructor
explains the process of chip placement
before telling the notifiers how the law
has changed to japan for the better the
national crime rate has decreased by
half while the gdp and productivity have
risen dramatically everyone listens to
the instructor carefully until a man
gets up and expresses his
dissatisfaction with the law he claims
that it is cruel and makes people live
in fear for most of their lives before
he finishes his speech some guards pull
the man out of the room and send him for
punishment it is then disclosed that
anyone who opposes the law is executed
following the person's removal the
lecture continues after being informed
about their impending deaths the
citizens will be given a paper called
the ikigami using it they can travel and
eat for free for the remainder of their
lives the ikigami also provides monetary
compensation to the family of the
deceased however if the person who died
has a criminal record the family doesn't
get any benefit with that being said the
instructor urges the notifiers to be
proud of their jobs the protagonist of
the film fujimoto is also an attendee of
the meeting and a new notifier on his
first day at work fujimoto is given the
file of a young man named tsubasa who
has been chosen to die the next day
tsubasa is a talented street musician
who is just gaining recognition and has
a bright future ahead of him this is
fine street musicians never have a
bright future ahead of them the only
people he is close to in life are his
single mother and his friend morio morio
and tsubasa have known each other for
most of their lives and are a musical
duo meanwhile tsubasa's mother only has
her son to rely on as she is growing old
when fujimoto reaches their home he is
told that tsubasa is out working on
being asked why he is here fujimoto
hands the ikigami to the mother telling
her that her son has less than 24 hours
to live the woman breaks into tears as
the nightmare she feared the most comes
to life she throws water on fujimoto's
face telling him to get out of the house
later tsubasa returns home and is told
about the ikigami he hopelessly sits on
his bed and remembers all the good times
he had in life the first face that comes
to his mind is his best friend mario who
he betrayed just some hours ago a
flashback of the days shows us that
fujimoto and morio were approached by a
reality show producer fujimoto was asked
to sign a deal with the company that
would kickstart his career but to join
the show he had to ditch his best friend
he signed the papers without thinking
about it but now that his death is near
he would rather have his friend than
participate in the stupid show the next
day tsubasa goes to an expensive
restaurant and enjoys a special feast
using his ikigami following the meal he
goes to mario and apologizes for what he
did mario's anger hasn't worn off yet
plus tsubasa didn't bring him for that
dope meal hence he refuses to listen
with nowhere else to be tsubasa goes to
the studio to take part in the show and
make a statement for the last time he is
paired up with a new guy who he is
supposed to sing with elsewhere mario
talks to subasa's mother and finds out
about the ikigami regretting not talking
to his friend for the last time he
quickly turns on the tv to watch him on
the show the performance starts and
subasa ignores the director's
instructions resorting to singing solo
rather than with the new partner knowing
that this is the last time he will sing
tsubasa pours his heart and soul into
the performance making people feel his
music he manages to accumulate his past
present and future into a single song
and dies right after the performance his
mother breaks down crying alongside
morio fujimoto who is also watching the
show is left in tears the incident goes
viral on the internet and shocks many
people a politician named kazuko takes
advantage of the death and uses it to
promote her campaign for an upcoming
election this is the most realistic part
of the story so far meanwhile fujimoto
is handed the file of his second client
named naoki he goes to the person's
house but no one opens the door just
when he is about to leave fujimoto spots
naoki through a window about to commit
the unthinkable he quickly breaks into
the house and saves naoki in the nick of
time however the guy is neither grateful
nor happy he starts hitting fujimoto and
only stops when someone opens the door
to the room it is none other than the
politician kazuko who also happens to be
naoki's mother upon finding out that he
is about to die she hugs him in tears
but follows it up by asking him to help
her in the campaign since he is
sacrificing himself for the national
prosperity law naoki always knew that
his mother was selfish but the comment
still takes him by surprise he loses his
mind and kicks everyone out of his room
fujimoto returns to his office and
reports the incident to his boss not
wasting more time he is handed the
second file of the day it talks about a
man named satoshi who has a blind
younger sister his parents died in a car
crash long ago which also took away his
sister sakura's vision the brother and
sister suffered financially after being
orphaned and had to live separately
since sakura was a minor that day
satoshi goes to her residence and asks
her to move in with him because he has
gotten a good job at a big company
sakura is skeptical having known that
her brother was involved in money
laundering but after satoshi assures her
he has left that kind of life she agrees
to move in with him later that day
satoshi goes to a gangster who is
revealed to be his boss he lied to his
sister about the job so she would accept
help from him elsewhere kazuko uses her
son's death in her next speech in hopes
that the people will sympathize with her
and shower her with votes naoki watches
the speech and burns in rage the fear of
death and hatred for his mother turns
him into a maniac hungry for blood
outside his room his loving father is
begging him to spend the day together
when he opens the door to check on his
son naoki has already left through the
window he is in the streets looking for
his first target just then he comes
across a policeman and beats him to
death before running away with his gun
using the weapon he goes on a killing
spree fujimoto is warned to be careful
because he might be on the hit list the
next morning satoshi buys a house for
himself and his sister he is excited to
start a new life and helps sakura go to
college at the same time fujimoto knocks
on his door to notify him that he only
has 24 hours to live when no one opens
it he leaves the number at the door upon
returning home and calling the number
satoshi is faced with the harsh truth he
crushes a mirror on the wall in
frustration just like his hopes and
dreams were crushed later he goes to
meet sakura but doesn't tell her about
the notice instead he decides to donate
his eyes to her right after his death if
his sister gets to see because of him
satoshi will be happy till the end but
he also knows that she would never agree
to go through surgery if she finds out
he will be dying the doctors and staff
at the hospital agree to help him keep
the secret they decide to operate the
next morning an hour after satoshi's
death in the meantime fujimoto finds out
satoshi's location and goes to the
hospital to give him the ikigami papers
while they are talking sakura overhears
the last part of the conversation and
asks satoshi if the ikigami is for him
he lies that fujimoto confused him with
someone else named satoshi sakura senses
that he might be lying since the time of
the ikigami's death and her operation
align she promises to go through the
surgery only after 10 am the next day
because she wants to make sure her
brother doesn't die satoshi confidently
promises her even though he knows it
won't be possible when she is not around
he loses his cool and attacks fujimoto
for ruining his plan fujimoto feels bad
for the siblings but can do nothing to
help them on his way back to the office
he notices naoki at the train station
looking at how he hides his hand he
seems to be carrying a gun to stop him
from causing more damage fujimoto
follows him and ends up in an election
program where kazuko is delivering the
last campaign speech kazuko notices her
son among the crowd and like the
self-centered idiot that she is assumes
that he has come to support her she asks
the people to make way for him giving
him a perfect line of shot fujimoto
tries his best to stop the guy but the
crowd doesn't allow it suddenly naoki
fires at his mother but misses the shot
chaos ensues as everyone starts running
for their lives naoki has the chance to
shoot her again but right then he
remembers the time she tried to stop him
from getting the chip embedded when he
was 10 she was vocally against the
national prosperity law until she became
a politician herself naoki finally
lowers his gun but is shot by a
policeman at that very moment his father
runs to catch him and witnesses his
death while holding him close fujimoto
observes everything from afar and is
overwhelmed with many emotions he has
seen so much sadness in this job that he
has to help sakura to redeem himself he
runs back to satoshi and suggests they
change the time on every watch in the
hospital to an hour early that way when
the clock hits nine sakura will think it
is 10 and allow for the operation they
talk to all the hospital staff and
patients and everyone agrees to help
fujimoto works the entire night to
create flyers explaining the situation
then they distribute it to everyone in
the hospital just to ensure sakura won't
find out about the plan in any way
because handing out a bunch of physical
evidence is super subtle the morning
comes and sakura is told the wrong time
she gets suspicious and starts asking
strangers if her brother is telling the
truth everyone having already read the
flyer takes satoshi's side eventually
sakura is happily taken for surgery at 9
30 am she thinks she will return to see
her brother's face only when she is out
of sight does satoshi break into tears
everyone who watches him mourn cannot
help but tear up in the following scene
the higher officials from fujimoto's
office are in a re-evaluation meeting by
helping satoshi in his personal matters
he has breached the employment contract
as a result his one year's worth of
salary and bonus is deducted and he is
sent to be trained again later fujimoto
is alone in a room with his immediate
boss he loses patience and claims that
the prosperity law is nothing but
[ __ ] before he can further express
his hate the boss stops him because
they're being watched he asks fujimoto
to keep quiet until it is the right time
to talk revealing that he is also
against the law soon the people will
speak they will protest and the
government will pay for killing
thousands of innocent citizens in the
last scene we see mario returning to
sing in the street in the memory of his
friend kazuko has lost the election but
her husband's spirit is as good as new
he plans to run in the election next
year and remove the prosperity law one
way or another sakura has also gone
through a successful surgery and has
regained her vision she is thankful for
her brother's sacrifice despite being
heartbroken about his death she visits
the house he bought for them and finds a
mirror as a gift from satoshi a note
behind it says that she is the most
beautiful girl in the world
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching